[Music]
warning us start out kick it off by
talking a little bit about the state of
database monitoring today we'll spend a
couple minutes on this talk about
stackdriver and bind plane and then go
into a demo and finally talk with one of
our early customers that are actually
using this solution but the reason to
talk about the state of database
monitoring is just to get on the same
page
can I ask how many people here is that
your kind of primary responsibility to
be managing databases inside of your
environment and then for how many people
is it kind of a secondary or tertiary
responsibility for you okay okay so I
would imagine a lot of you have already
been through this experience but in the
last five to ten years there have been a
couple of pretty significant changes in
the database landscape if we go back
that period of time a lot of companies
were really just focused on maybe one
proprietary database and they would use
that in almost every situation inside of
their environment and they would run
down the same thing so be a lot of times
you would have a proprietary database
that you're paying licensing fees for
maybe it was running on RAM on VMware
right and that was basically everything
that you were dealing with in it it was
much simpler than what we're seeing
today because really what we've seen
over the last few years is a pretty
quick migration not only to the cloud so
are dealing with that same database
it may be migrated to the cloud or may
be in both locations but then also in
the number of database types that we're
dealing with and that's really where
we've seen the biggest explosion so it
started with companies moving to open
source databases the same types of
relational databases but they didn't
want to pay those same fees that they
were paying in the past but they still
they still kept those prior that the
databases they had previously so I still
had the ad the Oracles and the sequel
servers but they just added in another
layer then really the next step was to
move to no sequel databases so a lot of
cluster databases and then finally we
move to fully hosted in the cloud
databases so really what that says is
all right we've got
hugely complex problem that we didn't
have to deal with a few years ago and
what we noticed that the tools really
haven't kept up so you don't have an
easy solution out there and that's the
problem that we're trying to solve here
with bind plane and with blue Medora or
with bind plane and staff driver so if I
step back and say let's let's start by
trying to find a common set of things
that we're looking for in all these
databases because we know we have maybe
we have half a dozen to a dozen inside
of our environments that we need to
monitor we want to try and find the
common threads between those and really
what we're looking for
in all situations is in roughly in order
we want to know the health and
availability of the databases we want to
understand the performance we need to be
able to see the performance of the
database and understand when there's a
clear degradation we want alerts from
the databases things like root cause
analysis so the ability to figure out
why this is happening and then finally
optimizations so the ability to see
capacity to plan capacity and we want
that across the board so so that's kind
of number one what we're looking for
here but it's it's a really good idea
not to stop there what we really want to
do is go one level further and look at
the infrastructure underneath it and
this is more challenging because we have
a situation now where you have some that
are in the cloud some that are on Prem
some may be in GCP but you may also be
using other public clouds as well and
that can be that can make these types of
metrics challenging but if you really
want to get to a spot where you're not
you know pointing fingers throughout the
organization it's important to have all
of these so this is the challenge that
we're faced with if we want to be able
to get those all those metrics and get
that visibility at the database an
infrastructure layer we have a lot of
data sources that we're going to that we
need to deal with from the metrics side
we have API metrics for a lot of your
know sequel databases for Cassandra
you're gonna have to go through an API
now of JDBC for all the
you know relational databases but it's
going to be different for each one we
have logs for queries and alerts for for
both of those and then the same thing
down at the infrastructure layer we need
to get the cloud metrics virtualization
metrics host logs for both of those so
getting all that - all of that and
pulling it all together is one of the
big challenges here so let's talk about
the solutions so Mike's just described a
sticky situation that a lot of us have
found ourselves in recently what can we
use what tools are available to help us
mitigate this to give us a single pane
of glass set of observability tools the
first I'm going to talk about is stack
driver how many of you are familiar with
our use stack driver okay so I'm gonna
I'm not gonna spend too much time on
this but I want to remind you just in
case you think it's part of stack driver
and you're not aware of all of the other
features stack driver is Google clouds
and monitoring and observability tool we
also have application performance
management tools as well stack driver
has three basic pillars there's
monitoring which will be our focus today
there's logging and there's APM as I
just mentioned and for all Google cloud
services this all happens automatically
you spin up your GCP instance of
whatever it is and you get your metrics
and your logs and stack driver without
any additional instrumentation so what
we're really talking about is adding
that level of observability for your
third-party applications that you're
running on Google Cloud or your
third-party applications that you're
running on Prem or in other clouds as
well as the underlying services that
you're using on Prem and other clouds
and what solution are we using to get
those metrics and those logs into stack
driver we're using blue medoras bind
plane bind plane is essentially an agent
as a service offering that allows you
for metrics to deploy a single metric
collector to you environment as long as
it can talk to all of your different
services that you're monitoring it can
pull those metrics together send them
off to bind plane and then send them
along to stack driver not going to spend
too much time talking through this
picture because you'll see our demo
later and that's a little more
interactive and exciting but I do want
to mention that bind plane supports
about 150 different services ranging
from bare metal Hardware all the way up
to to the third party application
services
and it's available at no additional cost
to stackdriver users so if you're
sending your metrics into stackdriver
you'll pay stackdriver for your custom
metrics but you're not going to pay bind
plane as well there's no added fee we're
talking specifically about databases
here and we did want to list out the
databases this is a list today there are
several others that are in the pipe but
find plane offers about twelve different
integrations if there's a database that
you care about that isn't on this list
come up and talk to us after come find
blue Medora at their booth or come find
me we would love to get your feedback
and there's a pretty pretty fast
turnaround time on all of the
instrumentation that's required to add a
new service we're also going to talk
about these specific types of
infrastructure it's a google cloud
obviously but also on-premise twelve
virtualized and bare metal and we'll
touch on other cloud vendors
observability as well again I'm not
going to go too much into depth with
this because the demo is a little more
interesting
but bind plane gives us a huge amount of
control over those metrics that we're
pulling from a given service you may not
be interested in anything and bind plane
gives you KPIs that are flagged as
things that you probably do want to
report on but this is just a view of the
level of configurability where you can
select exactly which metrics are
important to you and make sure those are
available in stackdriver and then you
can see here on the right what what sort
of observability looks like in
stackdriver we've got here a slow query
log showing up in stacker of a monitor
and so this is the solution that we're
talking about today centralizing
database monitoring across clouds across
on-prem with stack driver and bind plane
we are focusing on monitoring I do want
to mention that logging support is also
in alpha right now with vines planted so
if you're interested in joining that
program please come talk to us after
that really allows you to centralize all
of your signals for your databases in
one place all right demo time thanks Bri
so we're gonna go into a demo good talk
about a few different things one how do
you set up buying plane and snack driver
we'll do a quick overview of the statue
ever in the database
monitoring solution and then go through
how you would solve a couple of problems
using this combination and then at the
end I'm going to do tickets a few
minutes just to take a look at our new
logs alpha that we have available all
right so what we're looking at here is
buying plane it's a product by blue
Medora it's a SAS application and the
intent of it is like we've mentioned to
extend stackdriver beyond just Google
products into databases but also
infrastructure other clouds other
workloads that you may be interested in
and the way it works is we have in this
case I'm monitoring three different data
centers so the one data center on the
right is on Prem data center we're
monitoring VMware we're monitoring a
number of different physical systems
like pure storage some Cisco Networking
gear as well as servers and then a range
of different database types as well so
we're gathering all that data we're
sending it up to bind plane and then
it's going directly to stack driver we
also have a data center here that is GCP
based and in this case you'll notice
we're not monitoring GCP that as we
mentioned is already baked in so you
have availability or you have the
observability into all the GCP metrics
for the infrastructure but we do add
monitoring for things like databases or
any other workloads that you could be
running there and then the last data
center is another public cloud that
we're monitoring where we can pull data
from those specific services that you're
using there as well as databases or
other workloads you could be running the
idea is that you can use this even if
you are running on multiple clouds even
if you have a data center or have
databases on Prem we can pull it all
together into a single solution and then
get visibility to all that inside of
stackdriver
so let's take a closer look at the
collector first so I mentioned that we
have a collector installed in each data
center so this doesn't need to be
installed locally on your databases it
will connect remotely to those databases
as long as there's a network visibility
and we've made this as simple as
possible
to install so you just choose the
platform that you want to install it on
in this case I'm just gonna choose Mac
OS for a demo we have in most cases a
single line installer so we just copy
this paste it in my terminal and
depending on the network connection
speed here it's going to download the
collector and really this is a very
small small collector because it doesn't
have any of the plugin so the hundred
and fifty or so different extensions
that we support aren't downloaded all at
the same time what the collector does is
it's a simple Java based application
that can run any of these plugins that
I'm going to show you can gather data
and is fully fully managed by the bind
point service so it's one of the great
things about this is you are unlikely to
need to go back into the server to
configure a JSON file or modify anything
here we can handle that all remotely
through through bind plain itself so if
I flip back I see that the collector
that I installed locally has reached
back out to bind plain and it's
registered itself now if I wanted to I
can convert this to a group and this is
if you have very large environments or
you have availability requirements what
we recommend is building out a cluster
of these collectors it's very simple to
do and it'll automatically handle
failover as well as increasing the
throughput if you have a very large
environment but for now I'm just gonna
leave that single collector you'll see
that it's now available inside a bind
plane as my new dataset
which is just my laptop and we need to
add a source so you can see these are
the sources that we're currently
monitoring to us a source just means
could be a database it could be a VMware
instance vSphere instance it could be a
physical server and we can see all of
the sources that we have available so we
have public cloud vendors we have
physical compute so things like Dell
servers VMware vCenter instances the
databases which we're gonna talk about
more today things like load balancers
popular load balancers as well as
network switches physical storage so
your net app or your nimble or EMC is
all available and even some kind of
manager of managers or larger
applications like s AP i-- is JBoss so
it's pretty wide ranging and it's
rapidly expanding MacMurray said we're
always looking for feedback from
customers to hear what you're looking
for next so we can add that to our roam
app but today I have a Postgres database
that's running on my laptop so I'm going
to choose that I will choose the new
collector that I just created
and we'll configure it and as Mike is
configuring it we're going to ask all of
you to not hack his local Postgres
database using the credentials he's
about to type in
it's extremely secure yeah and no SSL
that's how I secure a database so we'll
test the connection and what this is
going to do so if I put in incorrect
credentials I'll even show you let's say
if this was wrong I hit test connection
this is going to attempt to login
attempt to collect data and then
identify if there are any problems so we
want to have a good tight feedback loop
to make this configuration process as
easy as possible and this is one of the
areas I think can be challenging if
you're doing with a large environment
and you need to get monitoring setup if
you don't have that feedback it can take
a lot longer than necessary it's really
simple this is pretty much what you
would need in the vast majority of
databases that you want to monitor just
a host a port that will will provide the
default and credentials and will let you
know if you click through into our help
settings will show the minimum user
required for every database type so
we're not asking you to give up admin
rights to a database to monitor it right
we will have the minimum required user
for each of these I'm gonna click Add
and this will now show up inside of my
environment and Mike what if I had a
bunch of environments that I wanted to
install the collector in that is a good
question so for customers that have
large large environments or a lot of
these we're not going to ask you to go
in through the API or through the UI
every single time we have an API
designed specifically for that to allow
you to script out the installation of
collectors even attach it to chef script
things like that so now you can see you
have a Postgres database it's collecting
data it's sending all that data directly
to stackdriver if I drill in probably
have all the metrics shut off right now
but just to give you an idea of the type
of things that we gather these are all
of the available resource types so you
can see we have obviously the databases
and the instances but also things like
the index the query query plans and more
and if I drill into one of these
civically you can see all of the
specific metrics that are available now
one of the things we do because we're
really intended we're intending to serve
a wide audience here and so we don't
expect you to necessarily need all of
these metrics and will let you know what
the KPIs are and what may most make the
most sense by flagging them here so if
you're setting this up and you're not
really sure what you want to look at we
recommend that you just enable the KPIs
to get started and for the folks that if
it's your primary responsibility to
manage databases there's a good chance
you know what you want to look at you
you have ideas of what those specific
metrics are and you can go through and
pick those out as well so that's an
overview of bind plain but now I want to
show you what it looks like we actually
jump into stackdriver
so this is stackdriver this is the
project that i'm sending all that data
to the first thing i want to show you is
just the access we have now so just like
with your google metrics click in here
oops
I just want to filter and show you that
we have so if I want to do a search on
Cassandra metrics those are all
available here let's say I want to look
for some Cisco hardware a little bit of
a slow search but is that the Wi-Fi in
movie theaters it's not always the best
show here there we go so now you see all
the Cisco so this be like your sis Co
hardware servers also network gear it's
all available everything that you saw
there that we're sending over is now now
shows up inside of your metric Explorer
and you can use it for everything that
you're normally using stackdriver for so
you can create alerts on it we have some
that are available here so like here's
an example of an alerts that we've set
up for a database specifically so it's a
buffer cache hit ratio check so we have
this on all of our sequel server
databases to flag when we notice that
there's a buffer cache hit significantly
below well or below one for over a
certain amount of time and that's an
important one for us to keep an eye on
and what we've done is you know just in
case somebody that may not be familiar
with this comes in and gets this alert
we want to make sure that it's really
clear what they need to do so we
provided the documentation links to
where you can go to get more details and
how to resolve that and what we're doing
today is we've built up a list of these
incidents that are available we can
provide them to you as part of the
installation process if that's helpful
or for folks that have a really good
idea of what they what they want of what
they need to see it's easy to build your
own and build your own alert structure
so the next thing I wanted to take a
look at was the dashboards and this is
just giving you an idea of what you can
what you can do with stat driver and
with all the information that's
available so in this case what I have
is one of those databases that was
running on Prem it's running on a pure
storage array it's using VMware it's
running a V Center as well and I have a
an issue that came in from a customer so
the application that's using this
database they've said that they've
noticed some deteriorating conditions
and so we want to go in and take a look
at how how do we find that how do we
find where that's coming from and this
is one of the big things that we're
trying to solve here is how do we
prevent teams from pointing the finger
at the other group right so is it a
database issue if you're on Prem there's
a lot of complexity is it actually a
storage issue or is it a virtualization
issue and that's what we're identifying
here so if you look what we've done is
pulled together some key metrics from
all of the components in the stack so
I'm looking at the peer storage host
latency which is spiky but nothing's
jumping out at me as a clear issue I can
go in and I see all right well I'm
seeing some repetitive vCenter host
memory used so these are spikes in the
host memory that that sequel server
database is running on I also see disk
weight and and I can drill I can
identify this specific database this is
running on so it's not disk weight on
temp TB or master this is specifically
on my app zero database so I know
there's wait time okay operations are
increasing as well seeing a large spike
in activation count and here here's the
problem
so I see specifically I can narrow it
down to the queries and I can get access
to that individual query the query text
that seems to be causing a major spike
at this time every hour so what I'm
going to do is go back if I'm the
application owner I'm going to take a
look at what's what's running this query
either optimize it or will modify the
frequency that that's running but it
lets you get through what could normally
take a lot of interactions bump jumping
back and forth between a storage team
virtualization team a database team or
the cloud team
so that's one example of an on-prem use
case let's take a look at something
similar in if you're running it in GC P
so really what I'm we're trying to show
here is side by side how can we use this
data in a way to help explain what's
going on and make it really obvious when
an issue at the infrastructure or GCP
layer may be occurring may be caused by
the database or vice versa and so what
we have on the left here these are
metrics coming from GC P so this is the
performance of the disk that a database
is running on and one thing I'll point
out is we see these these Reed spikes
right and so without any database
visibility I really don't know what's
causing that Reed spike but since we do
since we do have those metrics for the
the sequel server I can take a look at
that Reed spike that I'm getting from
GCP I can correlate it back to the
database that's actually that's running
on that and again I can see alright it's
my app GCP database specifically that
seems to be causing that problem and I
can go through active connections don't
seem to be at least thing to be spiking
a bit and again if there's a query
specifically related to that well it's
easy we make it really easy to find so
those are a couple of dashboards for if
you have a single kind of
mission-critical database or something
that you want to you want to really
focus in on but what about if you have
just a very large number of databases so
if you have several dozen that you're
trying to manage maybe they're all the
same type
maybe there's a variety and really what
you're looking for are outliers so if
you you want to find something that
maybe is experiencing issues inside of a
say in this case a sequel server farm
and this is really easy to do as well so
what we have in this dashboard is
we're monitoring three dozen databases
and we have some of the key performance
indicators for all of those so we can
identify when one of them is outside of
the norm whether it's things like disk
weight time you can see the cache hit
ratio the CPU usage queries instant lock
wait time and so a couple of things I'll
see you right away number one is that we
see some of these spikes that we may
want to investigate but also CPU usage
one I this is an unusual one that's very
low on CPU so maybe I'll take a look at
this and try to understand what's going
on with with this it's outside of the
norm so there's prod 5 and we can use
the normal filtering functionality
inside of stackdriver and if the Wi-Fi
comes through for us but let me give it
one more shot here
there we go there we go so now I've
narrowed it down to that specific into
that specific database and we can take a
look at what's going on and maybe get a
better a better sense of why this one is
is so long whether it's still needed or
maybe it's something that we can push
off to another database so those are a
couple of the specific ways that you can
use this in stackdriver
monitor your databases now before go
back I wanted to give a quick overview
of our our new logs feature as well so
if we flip over to logs number one I'll
mention this is an alpha so if it's
something that you're interested in
please talk with one of us we'd love to
give you access but it won't be
available out of the box and this is
very similar to to what we're doing with
metrics but since it's a lot since it's
logs focused it's going to run a little
differently you do require it does
require an agent on every database or
every workload or server that you're
trying to monitor but what we've done is
we've really tried to simplify the way
that this gets deployed the way it
handles collecting the logs and then how
it can be used inside of stackdriver so
you can see I have an agent I have it
pre-configured with a destination so
it's gonna send logs to stackdriver to a
specific project I've set up I have it
configured for Oracle here what if I
look at the sources there are a lot of
other sources that are available and
this is pretty early there are a number
here but we're adding to them very
rapidly so see a lot of focus on
databases to start and then that'll
expand out but if there's something that
you don't see here yet we also have
generic plugins that you can use to
gather data and gather logs one really
nice feature of both the monitoring
collector and this logging agent is
lifecycle management is you ever tried
to manage a number of different
components and keep them up to date you
know how challenging that is and this
just does that for you
yeah that's that's one of the things
that we've tried to focus on as much as
possible because we really believe that
there's been a folks have neglected that
side of monitoring it's it tends to be
really hard to get things installed or
harder than I think it needs to be to
get things installed and then keep them
up to date and since things change so
rapidly so for example we're building
these very very quickly we frequently
will release several per month or at
least updates per month it's not it's
not trivial to take that and move it out
to all of your environments so I have
one of these databases set up right now
it's just an Oracle database let's take
a look at the log so if I go into the
logs viewer first of all too much there
we go
so you'll see first of all I just want
to note that we have everything from the
Oracle audit log and a number of others
so alert Oracle alert log and I wanted
to show you that one of the really
powerful things you can do so you'll
notice here that I see I have a cyst DBA
user that has accessed or is something
to access something within my database
and within our environments that's
considered a major security flaw major
security concern if we see a lot of
these then we may need to take a look so
what I would what I would do is I take
that I can create a metric off of that
specific line log line and get an alert
set up whenever there's an issue
whenever I identify that that system a
user is in use and a couple of ways that
will come up is you'll see we have a
dashboard here specifically for Oracle
where we're combining those logging
metrics that we've created and the
traditional metrics that you're getting
from our original source into one
dashboard and this is useful because you
can see all right this this gives me
some insight into things like the
security
I can see how many of these cysts DVA
how much this DBA activity there is I
can also see if there are any failing
tasks this is something that you can't
get with just metrics but you can when
you extend it out to logs and then right
alongside that I have what you would
expect to see traditional metrics
monitoring Oracle session count session
utilization even CPU and query
information and again we have alerts so
if you have that alerts we can set it up
we can provide good guidance to the user
on and what the actual issue is how to
resolve that issue even reference
documentation and whenever you get that
you can automatically jump into logs and
take a look at the context around that
specific failure so let's take a look
and see all right well now I know
exactly where that occurred and I can
see the context what occurred before and
after so before I wrap up just wanted to
show you where you find this so we're
currently in the marketplace if you just
search for vine plain or blue Medora
it'll come up with our marketplace
listing and I'm already activated but it
gives you a quick overview and then you
just click a button it'll take you over
to bind plane you'll create an account
for your company and then you're ready
to go we're happy to jump on a call if
it's something that you know you want
assistance with getting started but like
I said this is or like Murray said this
is at no cost in addition to what you're
already paying for stackdriver and GCP
so with that I will hand it back over to
you Murray all right so we've just done
a slick demo showing you all the cool
things you can do with our new solution
that we're offering to you but now we
want to talk to an actual user real
human not fake who's using this today
and get his insights on what it's
allowed him to do and really what it's
enabled and I have to turn off this mic
so please welcome to the stage Jim
Wright of eastbound tech thank you for
joining us to money you tell us a little
bit about yourself so that's my name
that's what I do I'm a longtime user of
Google cloud specifically windows been
using it since they released it but have
only used stackdriver kind of
reluctantly because it was my
environments were so mixed with being on
on Prem and in the cloud and so that's a
little bit about where I'm at all right
and tell us about the databases that
you're working with what what sort of
things are you trying to do with them
what challenges have you faced so the
biggest challenge has been again the the
on Prem versus cloud where I've been
running a lot of Microsoft sequel on
Prem some of it in the cloud on Windows
servers and then running Google Cloud
sequel and then over on some other
platforms running some other databases
and so it's been a very mixed definitely
a mixed environment with a lot of
different databases and it's been
extremely difficult having like you said
a single pane of glass to look at all
those stuff and so you've been using the
blue Medora stack driver solution what
is that and allowed you to do so it let
me not renew my five figure solution for
SIEM last year it let me dump multiple
open-source solutions and actually
concentrate in one place which would be
stack driver I use chef to manage my
bind plane installations it's extremely
easy I would say I've spent we were
talking about this with these guys the
other day I spent almost no time in your
guys website not because I don't like it
but because it works it's simple
I'm in there I can figure my sources
collectors and I'm out and then I'm the
rest of the time and stack driver so
this has really given me a solution
where I can put a little bit of effort
and have a huge return compared to what
it
cost me to maintain my installations on
the open source solutions and the paid
solutions it's it's really really
simplified my monitoring of databases
not only that but of infrastructure as a
whole so I'm dumping all of my VMware
stats in there all of that info
everything from Windows it's it's you
know been huge for me to have a single
pane of glass and it's not it's not been
something that like some of the other
solutions you know you've had a lot of
promise up front of it'll be great it'll
be like this and this has truly been
working with the guys from bind plane
has been fantastic I've asked hey we
should do this or this would help me and
they're like all right sweet and then
it's out like the next week not that
they'll do that every time but they've
been extremely fast extremely responsive
so that's great and I thank you for the
strong endorsement so it sounds like
you're saving a lot of time with the
solution a lot of energy what's next for
you with all of that free time you've
got seriously mountain biking it's what
it's allowing me to give more meaningful
data and so are specifically on the
sequel side are monitoring and alerting
has been all over the place from
multiple companies and what this is
doing is it's letting me actually
consolidate and simplify so it really is
time-saving it you know takes time to
build out dashboards build out alerts
but so far it's been massively useful
[Music]